The jogan Experience where were we we
were talking about talk to me we're
talking about how the process from going
from um okay how to get the script
picked up to actually shoot so we got we
got yeah we we got a blackout in the
studio so we got to the script gets uh
approval you you manag to dodge all the
uh the obvious tropes yeah but I
remember going to the studios the people
that financed it were still iffy on us
directing they said to Sam our producer
they're like can you what what have they
done exactly can you send some stuff
they were still a little bit unsure cuz
it's a big gamble it's so much money so
we sent him the car hit video no yeah
well we just sent them some examples of
a more narrative driven video which our
YouTube videos never really were so it
was it was hard I remember we did a
short film called Deluge before we
started the YouTube channel so was there
talk of someone else taking it over
that's what they didn't say that
specifically the thing is like and one
of the reasons we didn't go with with
the Hollywood Studios because they would
have Final Cut and be able to make
changes and stuff and like every single
like shot and like sound effect and
everything was so like uh I guess have
like a strong sense of how we want it I
couldn't imagine having that control
taken away from us so doing the so we
went the independent route lost half the
budget and then it was It was supposed
to be an 8we shoot we ended up it
dropped was seven and a six and a five
so we had five weeks we lost an extra
million dollars out of the budget
because we uh cast Sophie Wild because
she wasn't a name yet like as a lead so
they took a million dollars away from
yeah but she was great she was
incredible she is the best and now she's
doing like she's got a lot like a lot of
stuff coming up which is amazing like it
was worth it to us because she was the
best like performer like I've never man
it's such a amazing experience having
someone that's like so good at their
craft and like will elevate it uh to a a
point higher than you could imagine in
your mind like we have a strong thing of
like how we want it to be You aming
artist like and they just fing elev she
was so committed there were days we
asked her not to sleep and come to set
not having slept her character is losing
her mind or she's meant to have been up
on that so she would do that there was a
scene where she starts like hitting
herself and she was so committed she
started beating the crap out of herself
for real she was just so caught up the
character in the moment yeah yeah yeah
she was like uh yeah and because it was
such a short shoot like uh we had to
really and it was it was during Co was
got like down but coming back up so if
you get if you get Co then you know you
can't come to set for a week or so it
was like Survivor on set like there was
one week we lost like seven people and
that was on Friday I'm like come Monday
There's going to be no one left like uh
yeah we was like losing so many people
everyone was constantly getting tested
and we knew if the production shut down
we yeah we weren't going to finish it we
weren't going to make it on budget there
was like budget set aside for certain
emergency situations but it was like
really really tight so we had to
reinvest all of our fees back back into
the film our producer reinvested all of
our fees back into the film to make sure
that we could get Sophie and it was just
a race for the Finish Line it was so
there was days that we have to shoot
eight minutes of the film in one day
usually on a film it's supposed to be
like on average what 90 seconds
something like that per day of filming
so how did the film get so
popular well so we had a was it just
Word of Mouth it well we got picked up
from so we got into Sundance Film
Festival which is like a really like
prestigious film f one of the biggest in
the world Sundance yeah uh and we got
into that somehow and then uh there was
I think like word started spreading
there so we were getting contacted by
like all the agencies like all these big
you know talent agencies and we're
getting like and they were getting
people to like reach out to us so we're
getting like two 300 emails a day of
like people like oh sign with us like
this thing so the word was spreading
before the movie even no one even saw
the movie I think they spoke to the
people at Sund like what's like a Buzz
title or something and that came up so
when we got there we it was like this
chaotic like yeah like a
strange everything we're trying to get
achieve in our life like being in film
was like and like scratching the door
forever it just like blew open and then
every was like like the most [__] it
was the most overwhelming we spent all
the Sundance cuz we had the crew there
in the cast everyone was just crying the
entire time it was so overwhelming and
even all those emails all these people
reaching out all these Heroes of ours or
all these companies that you've seen so
many products from saying oh do want to
look at this script I look at this it
was the first time I got so overwhelmed
I couldn't even open emails I couldn't
look or I was so did you just feel
surreal everything like Jordan Peele
sent a message like randomly and then uh
AR ASA who did hereditary he came to the
premere and like man it was there was
all this hype around the movie before
anyone saw I was like man I would have
rather it be like you no one knows like
you just go in not knowing expecting
anything there really high expectation
going into it we were sitting at the
back of the theater just cringing man
like oh like it was the most painful
experience cuz it was it was the first
time we were going to be exposed to
critics and like harsh critics you know
Sundance and and things like that and uh
we wanted audience members just in the
in the theater but I think it was all
just like industry professionals so it
was like it was terrifying it was it was
I was troughing so bad throughout the
screening thinking it was playing like
[__] yeah people would get up to go to
the toilet and they open the the back
door and then light would go over crowd
like a yeah it's just constantly people
are moving around I'm like what is the
movie boring why is people leing I think
and it was like a midnight screeny as
well like they play it at midnight in
Egyptian Theater was like a big famous
theater and like it was midnight so it
was late people like a little bit maybe
drunk
or it was like a weird yeah that whole
night I just remember being really
emotional and troughing a lot and and
cringing and tring uh in film like this
and Peaks and troughs Peaks and valleys
yeah it was like troughing and feeling
really down we went up to asked her to
apologize to him after the movie I
literally got up to say I'm so sorry you
got dragged here cuz of all this hype
for no reason I went to apologize to him
so I walked up to him I'm like bro I'm
so sorry that and he's like that was
amazing and I was like well what the
[__] and then he's so you thought it
wasn't being received well just because
people were distracted and moving around
or just you guys were hyper sensitive
hyper
sensitive yeah anything that was like
you know like a crackle in the speaker
or someone going to the toilet was
like thinking it was such heightened
emotional moment that every small thing
I was like this is playing like [__] so
when did you realize that it wasn't when
did you realize that this is a hit when
that night our producer said a24 want to
make an offer on the film and I was like
what the [__] a24 which is we would joke
about it on set oh this is very a24 this
film this is a very a24 shot you know
a24 no what's that so they're a
distribute a Distribution Company no
they're also like
a production company they're like the
most prestigious like like like kind of
Indie Studio thing like so like it's all
like they're really selective with their
talent and and it's kind of like art
films like can you give me an example of
a film movie Mao oh yeah oh x maacho one
of my alltime favorites that was yeah
I've watched that movie like 10 times
it's incredible God I [__] love that
movie which that's another great movie
yeah they got all good stuff uh uncut
gems uncut GS oh [__] I love that
movie yeah we love all these films as
well so they make dope movies amazing
movies oh everything everywhere all at
once too oh [__] the Daniels so that's
the thing we we were at a party once
with all those directors and actors and
stuff and it was like we never felt more
out of place cuz they're like you know I
know we're stupid D than proper film
directors we feel so uh unsophisticated
or or on a that's good yeah yeah that's
just authentic but oh yeah but yeah to
be a
stereotypical movie making human being
to make a great movie obviously yeah I
thank you than you yeah yeah it's like a
thing like I remember Adam Sandler
walked in the room and I was like
[__] Adam sand I'm like I want to say
something to him and I was like I was
like so like I was like meeting you and
I was he came up and I was like hey bro
big fan yeah and he's like we're having
fun he would walk past yeah it was
exactly that Michael starts being aany
cringing he here like I can't believe
I'm here like Michael [__] be
professional what are you doing yeah
like look we have to like wear a suit
and like sip martinis or something I
don't know no just be yourself be
yourself be annoying you know yeah just
be yourself
well I do have a nightmare of being
ourselves I have a nightmare of like you
like chewing me out on something and
then you know it's then I'll be all
comments on YouTube like hey look at
this [__]
guy look like like yeah [__] he show you
a nightmare of being here as well yeah
you has a nightmare of being here yeah
Jo I'm wait so whatever you say like I
agree with man please don't worry it's
working great no need for nightmares
this is
fun